Just wanted to share this before we
begin.
I got a text message and I told him I'd
bring it up
from George Janko.
Let me read it.
Okay?
So, I called him on the phone. Okay,
here we go. He reached out to me.
So, I'm going to read it. I called him
on the phone.
We have made peace for the glory of
Jesus Christ.
Jesus Christ. Sam, I want to say I'm
sorry
our episode ever came out. I truly wish
it had.
When we were together, my heart was only
to show you respect.
After the show, I was hurt when you
called me fake
and said I only do this for money. But,
instead of coming to you directly,
especially seeing you as my elder,
I answered through a podcast when
someone asked me about you. Ursula,
obviously.
That was wrong and I'm sorry. I don't
want to continue any conflict. My home
is always open to you if you want ever
want to talk. I pray
for you often and hope we both enter the
king together.
Okay, called him.
Apologized.
The Lord Jesus has forgiven us. We must
forgive each other. So,
may he forgive me
and I told him you don't need to
apologize.
It's forgiven. It's under the blood of
Jesus Christ.
So,
he does want to interview me
and talk about my journey, not about any
differences in doctrine. I said, "Lord
Jesus willing."
All right. I said, "Lord Jesus willing."
Once I lose this weight, I told him I
suffer with body dysmorphia. I've gotten
fat and it messes with me. I'm on the
path to lose the weight. In Jesus' name,
I lose that 40 lbs. I will join you as a
brother. So, it's been squashed. There's
peace.
We must forgive if we want to be
forgiven. We cannot hold grudges.
Right? And so, what I did was and I told
him there's only one video I could not
delete.
It's because I had a debate with an
Orthodox Jew.
So, I couldn't delete that.
But, you're going to see to show that I
want to truly
seek reconciliation with this brother.
As I said on Patrick Bet-David, he's
young. He's on a journey. He's going to
grow like all of us.
We must forgive when someone asks for
forgiveness. And I seek his forgiveness.
I didn't want to alienate him,
demonize him.
We must, if we fear the Lord and want
him to forgive. May God purify our
motives, purify my motives.
I am selfish and I don't want God to
destroy me. I fear the Lord.
Right? So, I removed the playlist.
Just to show you.
There's no George Janko playlist.
I tried to delete all the videos.
Only one I could not delete
because
I was debating an Orthodox Jew. I didn't
want to lose that.
So, it's gone. The only thing you're
going to find on George is two things.
I don't know why this keeps coming up.
Right?
Now, here I'm not saying anything
critical of George Janko.
Right?
Here, this is the one reason why I
couldn't delete this. That's it.
It's gone.
We must forgive. I must forgive. He must
forgive.
We have to forgive.
You want me there?
We have to forgive if I want to be
forgiven, I must forgive.
He came humbly. Look how humble he was.
He's on a journey. Love him, pray for
him.
Remember, 20 years ago, I hated
Catholics,
meaning the Catholic Church and
Orthodox.
Look where I am now. You don't know
where we'll end up.
You must forgive
if you want to be forgiven. Let me
remind you.
He's my younger Assyrian brother
and he loves Jesus and he's looking
to grow in his faith. He's on a journey.
And I didn't go there to bully him,
intimidate him. I came there to answer
his objections.
Right?
But sadly, things went sour and notice
notice what he said.
He did that podcast cuz someone asked
him.
You know who asked him? Ruslan.
Ruslan.
Okay?
He goes, "Rather than instead of coming
to you directly, especially because I
still see you as my elder, I answered
through a proxy when someone asked me
about you. Ruslan."
Right?
Enough said.
Don't want to say anything about him. If
Ruslan asked for forgiveness of
apologize, we'll forgive him, too. We
have to.
Let me remind you what our Lord says.
Warning to all of us.
Okay?
Warning to all of us. You good?
All right.
And then I'm going to open up. And I'll
talk about the Shaliah, but pray that my
throat gets perfectly healthy
within the next 3 days.
Who knows? Maybe the Lord takes me out,
but I pray I die forgiven and leave the
support for my daughters. He doesn't
need me.
As long as the Lord forgives me and
enters his presence, that's all that
matters at the end of the day.
Okay?
So, here you go.
So,
the brother showed genuine humbleness
and he humbled himself before me. Who am
I not to humble myself before him?
Right? I fear the Lord. I don't want to
be destroyed.
I don't want to go to hell.
And it's a healthy fear. I don't panic
cuz I know his heart. God is infinitely
loving and beautiful.
So let me show you and then we're going
to open them.
Lord, give us contentment and keep us
humble
for his glory. Glory to the Father, Son,
and Holy Spirit.
Good to see you, Lepanto.
Screen large enough?
Okay, right here.
In our Lord's Prayer, after he gives the
Lord's Prayer, "For if you give others
for their transgressions,
your heavenly Father will also forgive
you.
But if you do not forgive others, then
your Father
will not forgive your transgressions."
See that?
Ephesians 4:32
and I'll read the parable in a minute.
Okay.
You want to go watch a film now?
Ephesians 4:32, "Instead, be kind to one
another,
tenderhearted, graciously forgiving each
other,
just as God in Christ also has
graciously forgiven you."
Got it?
I forgive you for beating me up. You got
it.
Forgive me for beating me up.
She's 5'9" and she's starting to beat me
up.
I'll side kick you. No, no thank you cuz
you can kick like Chuck Norris. Bruce
Lee was better.
That's right. See that?
Ephesians 4:32
"Instead, be kind to one another,
tenderhearted, graciously forgiving each
other,
just as God in Christ also has
graciously forgiven you.
Colossians 3:13,
bearing with one another,
and graciously forgiving each other,
whoever has complained against anyone,
just as the Lord graciously forgave you,
so also should you.
You have to, right?
Right?
Yeah, Chuck Norris all day, huh?
Are you okay, you two over there?
Dancing in the dark?
All right, too much sugar in your system
today.
Matthew 18:21-35,
Then Peter came and said to him, "Lord,
how often shall I shall my brother sin
against me and I forgive him?" Member
girls, pray for me, my health, throat.
God hears you. Up to seven times? She
said to him, "I do not say to you
up to seven times, but up to 70 * 7."
But there's a condition.
When your brother asks for forgiveness,
you forgive.
That's Luke 17:3-4.
For this reason, the kingdom of heaven
must may be compared to a king
who wished to settle accounts with his
slaves.
Right, Rumble?
Okay.
When he had begun to settle them, one
who owed him 10,000 talents was brought
to him.
10,000 talents was astronomical.
It was a debt there would be no possible
way for you to pay in a lifetime.
Right?
I've even read
to you notes telling you
that a denari or dinar
was one day's wage.
I believe
a talent was the equivalent
of 300 days of wages.
Again, fact check me.
Uh the notes to your NET Bible will have
write that information. Nonetheless,
10,000 talents, astronomical.
You could not pay it in your lifetime.
Impossible.
It was an impossible debt.
Right?
See, there you go.
6,000 denarii, not 300.
So,
a denar was one day's wage.
A talent was
I'm sorry, 60,000. Oh, boy. Woo!
Is it 60,000 or 6,000, friend?
60,000
days of wages for one talent. So,
multiply 10,000 * 60,000.
See?
He owed him $60 million.
Impossible to pay
in your lifetime, meaning for those
people, obviously.
Right now, you got billionaires.
I miss me, too.
That's right, cereal.
Okay?
But since he did not have the means to
repay,
his lord commanded him to be sold
along with his wife and children all
that he had in repayment to be made.
Therefore, the slave fell to the ground,
was prostrating himself before him
saying, "Have patience with me and I'll
repay you everything."
Feeling compassion, the lord of that
slave
released him,
forgave him the debt. But that slave
went out and found one of his fellow
slaves, owed him 100 denarii, only 100
days of wages.
And he seized him and began to choke him
saying, 'Pay back what you owe.'
So his fellow slave fell to the ground
and was pleading with him
saying, 'Have patience with me and I'll
repay you.'
But he was unwilling and went through
him in prison until he should pay back
what was owed.
So when his fellow slaves saw what had
happened,
they were deeply grieved and came and
reported to their lord all that had
happened.
Then summoning him, his lord said to
him, 'You wicked slave,
I forgave you all that debt
because you pleaded with me. $60 million
you cost me.
Should you not also have had mercy on
your fellow slave
in the same way that I had mercy on
you?'
And his lord, moved with anger, handed
him over to the torturers until he
should repay
all that was owed him.
'My heavenly father will also do the
same to you
if each of you does not forgive his
brother from your hearts.'
See it?
See?
So,
I have to forgive
and I have to seek forgiveness
or I won't be forgiven. May God forgive
us for being selfish,
but that's a good motivation.
I want to be forgiven.
And what people do to me is nothing
compared to what we have done to the
Lord of glory, the Lord Jesus Christ.
So,
pray for the brother.
He's young.
By the time he gets 54, he'll blow me
out of the waters.
And it's not about being better than me
cuz I'm not the standard.
In
my journey, I went from independent
fundamental Baptist,
thought the Catholic Church was the
of Babylon,
becoming a The Calvinist,
didn't have
any higher view of the Catholic Church.
And look where I am now.
See?
You with me there?
But the condition again, for those of
you want to know,
when do you forgive? Watch.
The condition. When do you forgive?
Here it is.
There's a condition. It's even in the
parable.
What's the condition?
You must seek forgiveness.
Ask for forgiveness.
Right?
Therefore, the slave fell to the ground,
was prostrating himself before him
saying,
"Have patience with me and I'll repay
you everything."
Then he felt compassion and forgave him.
But now watch. When he found his fellow
slave
that owed him 100 denarii,
he fell to the ground, pleaded with him,
"Have patience with me and I'll repay
you." And he didn't.
Do you understand the condition?
All right. Now,
here again,
condition.
Luke 17:3-4.
"Be on your guard guard. If your brother
sins, rebuke him.
If he repents, forgive him. If he
repents, forgive him. And if he sins
against you seven times a Notice, and
returns to you
seven times saying, 'I repent. Forgive
me.' You see the condition?
You see the condition?
You saw it there?
They must seek forgiveness, ask for
forgiveness.
Then you must forgive. If they don't ask
for forgiveness, that means they don't
acknowledge they've done anything.
See
So, the brother out of nowhere today
Look.
Out of nowhere, Sam, I want to say I'm
sorry.
See that?
What do you want to be done?